ich würde gerne gleich zu beginn eckart
von hirschhausen frage neckar du als als
arzt unseres vertrauens ja was sagst du
mit blick auf berlin darf diese jamaika
groko verhandlungen
es ist gesund politiker zu sein man ist
dann über ewige stunden der
verhandlungen pappige brötchen man muss
dann auf der wahl nach stimmen dann
gerade als csu-abgeordneter irgendwie
mit getränken und leuten anstoßen die
man eigentlich nicht mag und die medizin
sagt nach einer durchzechten und
verhandelten nacht ja ist dein
urteilsvermögen so als hättest du über
ein promille also einen zustand den wir
bei keinem autofahrer akzeptieren würden
lässt einen immer noch 82 millionen
menschen dirigieren also ich hoffe dass
er jetzt mal was gescheites rauskommen
vor allen dingen für einen meiner
herzens themen dass es endlich mit der
pflege vorangeht das war für mich der
bewegendste moment im ganzen wahlkampf
geleistet ja auch immer wieder zum thema
gab das ja jetzt gerade mal 8000 pflege
stellen geschaffen werden sollen
das sind 0,6 pro einrichtung das ist ein
sitz oder war die jamaika koalition
schon mal bei 25.000 bisschen schneller
voran aber das heißt um dann noch einmal
darauf zurückzukommen wenn dieser so
lange verhandeln wenn die stundenlang
und nächtelang da zusammensitzen sind
die am morgen eigentlich in einem
zustand
ich würde da nicht als beifahrer
einstellen dass das erklärt natürlich
vieles von dir aber auch volksvertreter
sind ja teile folge sind auch menschen
dass das ist ja ist ja auch eine andere
politische taktik mittlerweile einfach
so lange zusammen zu sitzen bis der
erste ist der erste müde vom stuhl
rorstedt und dann hast du sozusagen
gewonnen aber was löst das aus diese
schlaflosigkeit im körper eines menschen
was passen das ist stress und du kommst
dann sehr schnell in so ein
entweder-oder ja/nein denken und politik
ist ja gerade die kunst des abwägens und
das leidet unter solchen schlechten
bedingungen also man kommt ja nein also
nur noch schwarz und weißen ja und
schnell nach hause und ins bett ging nix
sachen die eigentlich keiner erinnern
bei nüchternen zustand wieder gut
die kanzlerin zu zitieren mit dem satz
ich habe kamel artige fähigkeiten den
schlaf zu speichern
geht so was ja man weiß jetzt nicht
genau wo aber
tatsächlich an bord sein angela merkel
ist ja wahnsinnig c ja das ist wahr das
besser als sicher ein großer teil ihres
erfolges dass er irgendwann sagen die
einzige waffe am tisch neues aber die
möglichkeit gibt es und man kann
sozusagen für längere verhandlungen vor
schlafen ja aber was da passiert weiß
man sich ja doch also schlaf ist
existenziell also ja ich bin ein großer
fan der siesta dass man am nachmittag
kurz mal zehn minuten die augen zumacht
bei marx haben's ja ich bin damit meinem
bühnenprogramm muss ich ja abends fit
sein und 20 jahren jetzt los da erwarten
2000 leute dass ich weiter bin als sie
und das geht nur wenn du sozusagen ein
bisschen schlaf vor geleistet haben was
machst du da machst du so ein power
napping oder was ich habe die
bewundernswerte fähigkeiten mehr oder
minder überall einschlafen zu können und
das kann ich bin viel mit der bahn
unterwegs dann guckt man dass man
irgendwie in eine ruhige ecke hat neue
scan zu den kopfhörer auf und dann zehn
minuten für noise cancelling ja der
vater her hat kopfhörer die die
geräusche fernhalten das interessiere in
ohr
das macht einen großen unterschied ob
das klappt sagen schon runter kommen zu
ganz auf musik hören also dass er das
wäre auch ein tipp für berlin
vielleicht kommen besser ins wasser was
ist denn so zu sagen die die richtige
dosis gibt leute die sagen du schläfst
einfach solange ein da hast diesen
schlüsselbund in der hand und wände
herunterfällt und du wirst vom klimpern
dieser schlüsselbundes dann ist es zeit
wieder einer der schlüssel zu sagen die
zeit wo die muskeln entspannen
man kann sich auch ein wecker stellen
man hat eigentlich selber ein gutes
gefühl wenn du aufwachst und liederbach
bist und nicht nicht so ein hangover
hast das ist ein gutes beispiel
ich merke aber jetzt wo ich tatsächlich
so viel abgenommen habe ich brauche auch
weniger schlaf ein guter teil des
schlafs ist ja nur verdauung also man
merkt er immer nach dem dicken essen
bist du sehr müde
und seit ich das mit den essens pausen
machen und einfach längere zeiten auch
nichts zu mir nehme bin ich wach und
brauche auch weniger schlaf ist wirklich
verrückt was das ausmacht
ja also ich glaube körperliche fitness
einfach schlicht und ergreifend führte
oder hin dazu dass man weniger schlaf
brauchen wie es denn heute so der der
stand der medizin wie viel schlaf
brauchen wie er ist ungefähr das was ist
eine gute dosis die die mediziner ist
bis heute nicht warum man eigentlich
schlafen muss ich finde die frage viel
wichtiger wo für wird
also tiere werden hier wache um sich
fortzupflanzen und um nahrung zu suchen
ist eine idee zum beispiel genau und
danach kann man wieder schlafen aber man
man man weiß nicht warum man schläft
oder oder den neurologischen gängig
kaffee weil sie denken sie müssen
wachbleiben aber mein rat wäre gut
ausgeschlafen sieht die welt ganz anders
in der tat du sagst gerade abnehmen du
bist schlank geworden dass ich auch ein
auto gesehen wie ich das letzte mal hier
war da hatte ich echt über zwölf kilo
mehr als heute
12 ich habe ja eine neue zeitschrift
amtiert stern gesund leben mit großer
erfolg immerhin sind ja das hat mich
total gefreut da ist deshalb wurde uns
wirklich aus der hand gegeben das hat
keiner für möglichkeiten 200.000 waren
ich weiß doch für vorne drauf hin zum
komischen salatblatt das hat allein
deswegen habe ich mir das gekauft und
ich wollte nicht mal so ein stelzen mit
basilikum entschuldigung mehr für den
kopf wenn ja aber die die botschaft ist
eigentlich verblüffend einfach nämlich
ist was du willst mache nie wieder geben
aber ist halt nicht ständig sondern
macht pausen intervall fasten ist ja als
mag das wort nicht ich wäre essens pause
nach zwei klar worum es geht weil unser
körper zwei betriebsarten die eine ist
nahrungsaufnahme die andere ist los
werden und um in diesem modus zu kommen
musst du erst mal eine pause haben und
das ist total natürlich die leute sagen
wie kann man den 16 stunden ohne nahrung
bleiben das war immer schon so in der
geschichte der menschheit ja eine andere
stadt nicht um 12.30 dem mittagessen auf
den tisch das lief noch zwei tage vorher
sind programmiert für wenn es etwas gibt
genau und danach mache aber pause und
wir haben ständig rein ohne pausen zu
machen und die ernährungswissenschaft
hat soviel uns in die letzten 20 jahre
erzählt von wegen wir brauchen alle fünf
mahlzeiten und frühstück ist das
wichtigste und so weiter
ich habe jahrelang gefrühstückt ohne
sich wirklich großen hunger hat und
morgen ich dachte das muss sein muss
überhaupt nicht sondern gar nicht wenn
du erst ab zehn sozusagen mit
kalorienaufnahme anfängt und bis 18 uhr
ist was willst kannst du in den zeiten
danach auch wunderbar verzichten und hat
16 stunden wo dein körper zur ruhe kommt
die bauchspeicheldrüse kein insulin
ausschütten
du hast wirklich echtes anti aging eben
in der maske sagte
ihre haut ist viel besser geworden wären
wir natürlich als typen nie aufgefallen
aber frauen merken was ja natürlich
frauen sehen das so vor ich habe aber
auch gesehen du siehst du jahre jünger
das sollte ich doch sagen an der stelle
hat sie doch verabredet
20.15 uhr für besonders schöne
kompliment den vorfall aber dieses
intervall fasten er hat erklärt dass
einmal was bedeutet dass es heißt du
isst und dann machst du wie lange pause
was ist die idee dabei die methode hat
16 zu 8 ich habe mir noch nicht
ausgedacht sich die zeitungen als chance
geben möchte ich möchte ich bei aller
bescheidenheit sagen das haben andere
leute ich hab mich so gelöst eigentlich
seit jahren darüber aber aus amerika
kommen glaubt populär geworden und das
freut mich weil du musst kein pulver
kaufen muss keiner sekte beiträgen muss
nicht ideologisch irgendwie der
ständigen kopf machen was ist gesünder
34 com brötchen oder 43 konnten wir sind
ja die diskussion auf die keiner mehr
lust hat und deswegen sage ich erst was
ihr wollt aber halt nicht die ganze zeit
zählt keine kalorien zählt stunden ist
worauf du lust hast einige stunden lang
genommen acht stunden lang und dann
machst du 16 stunden am tag nach 18 uhr
habe ich heute nichts mehr gegessen weil
es ja jetzt schon jetzt danach das
gleiche
das heißt du bist eigentlich sehr
unterzuckert gerade ja merken wir dass
ein bis leicht reizbar merke ich ja ich
war sehr aggressiv
[Gelächter]
das jetzt auch schon deutlich gemacht
dass er schon seit seit november im
januar stehen deshalb im nächsten jahr
werden wir alle
alle fragen die es dazu gibt auch jeder
beantworten weil die leute wollen
wirklich haben sie uns das geheimnis
nicht verraten ich sagte er
geheimnisvoll wie hält man das denn aus
seit er 16 stunden ohne essen die hälfte
schläft er davon ja aber da die meisten
leute haben kein problem damit im schlaf
nicht zu essen das ist eine der sachen
klima die experten ziemlich sicher
die machen das den fußball-profis
diesmal ja das ist heute wahrscheinlich
anders wie es vor 15 20 jahren war
da ist die wissenschaft etwas
fortgeschrittene wie damals mich würde
interessieren
ich kann nicht schlafen wenn ich hunger
habe man hat dann auch keinen hunger
mehr also gewohnt sich der körper daran
will ich die ersten drei vier wochen
sind natürlich eine zeit der umstellung
vor allem wenn man das jahrelang anders
gemacht hat aber dann geht's und das ist
verblüffend einfach und ich habe auch
nicht das gefühl dass ich mir was
versage also der trick bei den
essenspausen ist ja bei jeder diät
konzentriert man sich ja irgendwann so
sehr aufs essen die ganze zeit dass man
verrückt worden
und irgendwann kommt die gegenreaktion
ja männer denken dann also jeder hat
doch mal versucht und wieso eine scheibe
gucke auf drei mahlzeiten zu verteilen
und dann denkst du jetzt habe ich den
ganzen tag mich daran gehalten jetzt ist
dunkel jetzt gelten andere gesetze und
dann gehst du zum kühlschrank und männer
denken dann
merkt der körper nicht was ich eine
freie presse darf nur in der küche das
licht nicht anmachen also wir haben dann
alle also total idiotische regel wo wir
denken jetzt auch egal
und diese gegenreaktion ist natürlich
der grund für das jojo und wenn man
langfristig eben deswegen mag ich auch
nicht hirschhausen geht es ist keine
diät ist eine art zu leben und das leben
heißt ist das dir spaß macht - und dann
machst du ne paar wirklich ist was du
spaß macht also ich weise dieter und ich
werden so die fraktion morgens um zehn
erst mal currywurst und mittags dann
pommes abends vielleicht eisbahn
das würde inzwischen ich bin ja auch
völlig juli frei unterwegs aber ich habe
gar keine große lust mehr auf fleisch
also ich hab jetzt zieht er los eckert
ja auf süßes habe ich früher tonnen
schokolade marzipan sohn kennen ich
werde immer süßigkeiten in sicherheit
gebracht und hier chancen kam
[Applaus]
als arzt der nation kann es ja nicht die
ganze den leuten sagen was gesundes
leben ist und selber ungesund ja ich hab
mal meinen bauchumfang gemessen das
mache ich auch bei meinen live programm
kriegen die leute so ein zentimetermaß
und dann weißt du schon mal ich habe mit
so einer kleinen lampe auf zwei jahre
lebenserwartung verzicht und das ist mir
nicht wer was ist denn so ein gutes maß
von body mass index für dietmar oder
mich also bei die mass index ist so grob
25 ich war zwischen 25 und 30 unterwegs
über 30 das ist mein fettleibig
bauchumfang ist zwischen männern und
frauen ein bisschen unterschiedlich aber
ich sag mal über meter hast du schon
erhöhtes risiko bei den männern du nicht
so dass kein problem aber viele leute
zugucken können da neugierig werden ich
sage auch kein mensch muss abnehmen
jeder kann so dick und fröhlich sein wie
er will ich möchte überhaupt nicht
sozusagen als moralapostel sagen alles
nanometer sagt mich hat es beschäftigt
also sagte ich ich will nicht unnötig
sozusagen ständig so eine entzündung
haben in meinem bauch ist dass das was
da passiert genau
also ich hab mal gelesen dass das fett
das in den liegt vor allen dingen das
problem ist ja dass ich über die organe
legte uns einfach gesagt eine andere
verteilung
des fettes die bei den frauen ist es
ungefährlich als bei den männern bei den
männern ist es um die augen herum und
bei frauen
guck mal genau hin da rutscht erst
einmal woanders hin
das ist ungefährlich ja das kann ja auch
sehr schön sein und das heißt dass die
männer an das problem die frauen haben
das bewusstsein und die männer sind
eigentlich die die auch den preis dafür
zahlen dass sie früher sterben und
deswegen mit der man fünfzigsten
lebensjahr und meinem die bühnen thema
endlich habe ich noch überlegt menschen
was willst du umsetzen was dir wirklich
wichtig deswegen dass das merke ich
somit mit 50 ich werde jetzt
interessierte an themen die relevant
sind und deswegen sage ich
gesundheit ist das eine aber eben auch
die frage ich kyte ist so ein thema
beschäftigt sich das also dieser
fünfzigsten geburtstag ist er gemerkt
hat keiner geklatscht die leute waren
kurz davor taschentücher zu reichen nein
jetzt ein problem hast oder wenn du
nicht 50 euro gegeben
ich habe meinem programm habe ich eine
live projektion wo man sein geburtsdatum
eingibt und chris errechnet wir leben
jeder hier fünf jahre länger als der
globale durchschnitt wenn leute sagen
ich habe keine zeit ist einfach gelogen
haben so viel zeit wie noch nie zuvor in
der mensch hat geschafft was wird
wertvoller natürlich dass wir wertvolle
und ich merke eben auch dass mich
das interessiert ich sag immer ist in
fünf dinge die über 15 jahre an
lebenserwartung entscheidendes bewegt
dich rauch nicht gemüse erwachsenwerden
kind bleiben fertig du brauchst keine
creme dafür aber anti aging das
schlimmste was passieren könnte ist das
funktioniert ja dann wird körper wird
jünger dein geist wird ja älter
irgendwann hast du als einmal dein
körper kommt wieder zurück in die
pubertät du kannst wieder weiß aber
nicht warum das ist ja kein
erstrebenswerter die mittlerweile
gemacht weil das passiert ja schon an
menschen die sich konservieren lassen
sie sich einlassen schwachsinn also
endlich dass man sich damit anfreunden
dass das eben zeit kostbar ist dadurch
dass sie zu ende geht und im silicon
valley fangen jetzt an sich einfrieren
zu lassen weil sie sagen in 500 jahren
kann man mich auftauchen dann ist der
medizin weiter und wird man mich wieder
reparieren bin ich wieder dabei
das ist totaler bullshit das
funktioniert nicht mal suppenhuhn ja da
ist auch kein kopf dran aber das wird
doch wenn du es auftaucht weiblich aber
nicht lebendig und genauso es ist nicht
zu erwarten dass in 500 jahren irgendwie
auf uns gewartet hat ja wir hinterlassen
den nächsten generationen ozeane voller
plastik atmosphäre operation zwar jetzt
auch noch unsere unheilbaren in
tiefkühltruhen was soll das denn
also die die ideen wie ich versuche da
ein bisschen kabarettistisch humorvoll
rüberzubringen heißen eben auch
freundlich damit an freudig aufs alter
während ich schreibe gerade mit tobias
eschenbacher der professor der hat sich
ganz viel mit dieser mit der frage was
neurobiologie des glücks und selbst
beschäftigt und er hat ganz spannende
these er sagt nämlich nach 50 geht das
leben noch mal bergauf mit der
zufriedenheit von frieden halten es laut
herbst kommt dann kommen wir gerne weil
die these ist in meinen augen
revolutionär
die meisten leute verbinden mich mit
meter werden immer ein abnehmen von von
fähigkeiten denkt nach man muss ewig 17
dann muss man überhaupt nicht die
meisten leute sind zufriedener in der
zweiten hälfte des lebens oder
[Applaus]
wir reden uns das jetzt nicht gerade so
ein bisschen schön das ist gefährlich
sagt also irgendwann so die die eigene
endlichkeit langsam bewusst wird ja ich
finde schon dass das ein schmerzhafter
prozess ist und man muss schon mit allen
leuten alles beweisen ich finde das ist
auch nicht das jahr des gutes hängt
natürlich auch eine persönliche
lebensgeschichte wie die dinge für dich
gelaufen sind und so weiter also ist
gelassener du wirst erfahren mehr über
dinge lachen und ich weniger also nicht
einfrieren lassen als durch
ich habe ich meine große sorge ist immer
wenn man sich einfrieren lässt ja die
frage ist wer sollte ein interesse daran
haben sich ja mal wieder auf und wartet
auf dich ein 500 jahre taucht mich
wieder auf dass ich ja oder dann wachte
auf und ist erst mal die strom brechen
will also ist der qualität jajaja soll
sich auf fast zu freuen im älterwerden
ist auch eine kunst also ich sammle
inzwischen ganz bewusst deswegen auch
jane goodall oder eric kandel oder ich
suche oder ich hatte in meiner in
weyhausen christenmenschen 83-jährige
salzer tänzerin war der hammer
das heißt in dem moment wo du positive
vorbilder hast ja lebst du anders und du
lebst länger das anti aging heißt nicht
das alter vermeiden sondern zu gestalten
und das ist doch eine tolle chance dass
wir heute mehr zeit haben als jede
generation vor uns und macht das einfach
nur laufen und ich gelesen dass leute
die sich regelmäßig bewegen dass deren
hirnstruktur anders ist ja das ist der
sportler die sec diese gründe die wir da
außen haben ja die außen
die wirtin wie dicker jahr diesen leuten
meines verhindert offenbar demenz
erkrankungen und alzheimer das ist
dieses jahr der mensch ist ein ist viel
bewegung gemacht sitzen ist das neue
rauchen ja und deswegen in meinem
programm gibt es immer was zu lachen
aber es gibt auch sozusagen ideen die
man mit nach hause und ganz banale idee
ist die leute sagen immer ich habe keine
zeit mich zu bewegen weil ich guck doch
mal auf eure mobiltelefon rechnungen
verstehen nämlich die minuten drauf die
den monat hast und ich habe mir
angewöhnt bei längeren telefonaten
vor sprich jetzt wieder eine andere
gutes beispiel da gehst du einfach dabei
um block dann musste halt kurz mal
erklären warum jetzt anfangen zu stören
wenn es bergauf geht das nicht jetzt an
den fragen vielleicht wieder bei
unternehmern zum stöhnen sind auch vom
festnetz aus günstiger aber du merkst
eben wie du im alltag bewegung unter
christ und ab 15 minuten geht der
lebensrettende effekt schon los
15 minuten ab funktionen am tag dass ich
ewig ein fan von wie viel haben wir
letzte frage erklärt wie viel zeit haben
wir selber sozusagen in der hand da
sowie viele jahre können wir rausholen
muss einigermaßen vernünftig bewegen und
das mit dem eisbein lassen das sind
wirklich 15 jahre unsere unserer
lebenszeit hängen von diesen ganz
einfachen lebensstil beschlossenen jahre
und deswegen bin ich auch so einen
freund von prävention von
gesundheitsaufklärung von
gesundheitskompetenz das gehört in die
schulen das gehört in die kindergärten
mit mit fußball mit sport die leute zu
begeistern da für euer körper ist ein
wunderwerk ja und den zu pflegen und zu
schätzen und zu wissen was dem gut tut
und was eben auch nicht das ist für mich
bildung und das unterscheidet es gibt
keine tablette keine operation habe kein
künstliches organ nichts was an die
andere wirkungsvoll ist die freude am
leben und das ist und du machst dir
keine großen gedanken dass ein gast
bis die ersten gefährt en
sagen wir mal ein gespräch lesen mit
henning mankell ja ja auch krebs
verstorben ist leider der den man sagen
wir machen uns viel zu viele gedanken
über den tod es ist noch keiner lebend
aus der sache raus gekommen wir sollten
nicht so viel darüber nachdenkt findet
da hat er recht gehen den frauen ärgert
besser mit dem alter mit vergänglichkeit
mit endlichkeit um als männer
oder sind männer da entspannter frauen
lieben ja schon mal länger als männer
und deswegen haben sie auch oft die
chance dann zu dingen zu kommen wenn die
männer nicht mehr weg sind ja da gibt es
richtig fertig sein hier aus deinem
alten punkten den höheren satz zu
zitieren wenn er ab lebt lebt sie auf ja
dass er sie jetzt einfach mal so stehen
[Applaus]